[Music]
hello and a very warm welcome indeed to
quadriga coming to you from the heart of
Berlin and this week the focus is on the
dangerous standoff between Iran and the
u.s. in the Persian Gulf where each side
is accusing the other of aggression
tension rose in July when Iran seized
the British tanker the US and the UK are
both stepping up their military presence
in the region but Europe or at least
continental Europe is refusing to get
onboard the us-led naval mission and is
instead continuing to put its faith in
the nuclear deal struck with Iran in
2015 which President Trump withdrew
America from last year so our question
this week here on quadriga is Iran
crisis Europe on the sidelines and to
discuss that question I'm joined here in
the studio by a leaf atoll and a jet a
Middle East expert with think tanks like
the Brookings Institution and the German
Council on Foreign Relations he argues
that the big challenge is to transcend
two equally simplistic perceptions of
the Islamic Republic Europe's tendency
towards glorification and Washington's
pancha for demonization also with this
is Alan Posner a regular commentator for
the berlin-based daily de Velde
he believes that Europe is on the front
line of Iran's aggression if we choose
appeasement he says we will pay dearly
for our cowardice and a very warm
welcome to - Arika Hammond who's a
business journalist with another Berlin
Daily the target site on all the taxes
it's also known at all Rika argues that
the oil price is not rising the economic
indicators suggested there is no real
Middle East crisis on the horizon I'm
very surprised by that you know the
summer's so much into so much evidence
that the situation is tense and getting
tenser and you're acting with rigor as
though it's all going to blow over
sometime very soon well I'm not saying
that the markets always right they might
know perhaps they are too lazy to
recognize the danger but it is
interesting that in the middle of such
upheaval politically there is the
so much calm when it comes to the
markets and well and so apparently the
traders think that there's nothing going
to happen because otherwise the oil
price would rise because 90% of all the
Middle East oil or the the Gulf region's
oil is being transported through the
Strait of Hormuz who are talking about a
sense of deja vu they're talking about
the provocation the counter provocation
the the non verifiable claims that are
being made by each scientist they're
saying that it feels so much like 2003
and the Gulf War back then yes probably
about you know the biggest mistake ever
made by the US in this region was
exactly this war against Iraq and I
can't imagine them repeating this very
big mistake because by destroying the
Iraq base somehow pushed Iran into the
position that has now so I don't really
think that the Americans are keen on
having another war going and last point
is that probably is that trumps start so
many conflicts he's got a conflict with
China going on he's got a conflict with
the zone it said hey you know if every
day there's new conflict so it is very
hard to somehow still think it's really
serious mm-hmm
no Turkey very seriously a little on
edge at the International Crisis Group
has made its contribution it's come out
with a drastic you'd have to say
assessment of what's going on let me
just quote from it it says it's all
about averting the Middle East 1914
moment and says that the situation is
reminiscent of tensions on the eve of
World War one strong stuff what do you
make of it well first of all I didn't
read the report and usually the
publication's of the International
Crisis Group are quite solid but I'm not
sure if this historical comparison is
correct because if we for example
compare the situation today in the
region with that of indeed eve of the US
invasion of Iraq we see that geo
politically speaking there is no
comparison whatsoever because Iran is
much stronger in the region and of
course the US military and a lot of
actors in the region
know that so they know that the
ramifications of a large-scale war would
be incalculable for all actors involved
and this is still the case so that
neither the Iranian side nor the
Americans are really interested in a
large-scale conflagration but it doesn't
mean that because of the volatility of
the region we won't see any further
steps of escalation because the ICG does
also say that even a small scale
incident could trigger a bigger
consulate and there are enough parties
involved in the conflict who might want
to you know do that actually do that
trigger a conflict absolutely we have a
highly militarized Persian Gulf region
in the wake of the most recent incidents
in in that part of the world and so the
issue of miscommunication or the lack of
communication and you know the density
of military you know material in the in
in that particular region is of course
you know posing a very strong risk and
there are also hardline elements on all
sides who might want to see you know a
smaller scale military conflict from
which they think they can benefit Helen
you say Europe is on the front line of
Iran's aggression house of Europe look
quite generally speaking this this
conflict started when when the British
seized an Iranian tank off Gibraltar
which was bound for Syria Syria is has
been the object of Iranian aggression
they basically occupy the country their
own the the country and we've seen one
result in a huge wave of refugees so we
are on the front line of Iranian
aggression in that respect also we are
though we in Germany are more dependent
on Russia Russian oil and we are an oil
from the Persian Gulf we certainly
Europe as a whole is much more dependent
on oil from that region than for
instance the United States which is not
moral importance and oil exporter so we
should be taught we in Europe should be
much more worried about what Iran is
doing then for instance America needs to
be and and and we talked about this as
if it were a conflict between you know
Trump and the ayatollahs but in fact
Donald Trump has no interest what
ever in you've said it I'm not gonna you
know gue repeat all the reasons he would
be scared stiff many good reasons to
start a big war on the Gulf it's us who
should be asking ourselves what's
happening and why we aren't doing
anything when you ask those questions
you use some very emotive language if we
choose appeasement we will pay dearly
for our cowardice yes why do you choose
to use such emotive such such burdened
language well I not because I think you
know appeasement is a word from the 30s
not because I think that Iran is it's
comparable to Nazi doctrine let's be
clear but the fact is they aren't
heading for world domination but they
are heading if they don't already have
it for regional domination and again
this is our neighborhood it's not the
neighborhood of the United States and if
Iran controls the region destroys Israel
of a as they have pledged to do create a
Shia dominated Middle East with with
millions of Sunni paying the price as
they are doing in Syria and so on then
we in Europe will pay the price the oil
will will break down we'll have even
more refugees we will sooner or later be
forced into a military conflict
somewhere if not in the Persian Gulf
then maybe in Lebanon or eventually in
in Turkey wherever we don't know we have
to stop Iranian aggression now and we
can do this the completely wrong
attitude because you know once you have
once you threat you are threatening the
Iran all you achieve is to have the
Ayatollah regime being strengthened
because you know most Iranians after 40
years of really religious dictatorship
would love to change the regime but they
it's not possible as soon as you start
attacking the Iranian regime from
outside of course everyone in Iran has
to somehow to stand behind the regime
because they don't want to be they don't
want to risk to have any invasion by the
US
anything so you can't have an internal
upheaval which most Iranians would love
to have if you have this threat from
outside so you know you all you achieve
it's just the opposite of what you want
don't get the logic sorry no I think
we're talking about two different issues
about the geopolitics of the region
where you'd you know point it and then
quite a stark terms I have to say to the
role that Iran plays in the region and
undoubtedly it's it's a negative role
but part of the picture is also that the
other side of the coin of those
problematic actors in the region is also
Saudi Arabia so we have not only you
know limited to Assad right there in
Iran I can also think of other
problematic actors but what is true of
course is is that in particular in the
particular cases of Syria Iraq and
partly Yemen you know and Lebanon Iran
is playing a you know a problematic role
but then in other theaters would argue
that it's Saudi Arabia that is playing
you know the the the primordial bad role
so to speak so I think what we need is
that we have to be critic critical
visibly both actors in the region and we
have to understand that both Saudi area
and Iran are playing their part in in in
this kind of tumultuous you know
geopolitics of the region the other
question is how do we devise any kind of
Iran policy that is not strengthening
the regime you know that is not
producing the kind of dynamics that you
have laid down so what we've been seeing
a decade ago is that the crippling
sanctions regime you know imposed by the
Obama administration of course has you
know weakened civil society and
strengthens those political economic
actors within the regime who have
privileged access to resources and then
you know ken does externalize the cost
of sanctions on to the civilian
population so we see a similar dynamic
right now on the other hand we also see
a lot of pressure imposed upon the state
you know in the wake of sanctions for
example if you look at figures of
Iranian oil exports we see that despite
you know a lot of claims to the country
the u.s. economic pressure strategy has
been quite successful so I think there
are different facets of you know of
sanctions policy of policy in general
that we have to take into
and we have to make sure that this is
not a policy that is you know very much
playing into those hands that we don't
want to see them okay before Alan comes
back in we've had our first impressions
of this simmering geopolitical showdown
between Donald Trump's America and the
Islamic Republic of Iran let's just take
a quick look at the recent chronology of
the conflict and then we will come back
to Alan poster with the stroke of a pen
president Trump announced the u.s.
withdrawal from the Iran nuclear deal
just over a year ago he imposed new
sanctions and threatened those who trade
with Iran what followed was a steady
escalation of tensions between the two
countries Iran began to enrich more
uranium several oil tankers were
attacked in the US declared Iran to be
responsible Britain impounded an Iranian
oil tanker off the coast of Gibraltar
here an Italian a British tanker in the
Strait of Hormuz tensions peaked when
the u.s. deployed an aircraft carrier
and bombers to the Persian Gulf Trump
threatened to obliterate her and yet
called off a planned air strike at the
last minute war with Iran is the mother
of all wars countered Iran's president
Hassan rouhani though he signaled a
willingness to talk
just a lot of saber-rattling before they
sit down at the negotiating table the
question is it a lot of saber-rattling
or is there more to it
well the again the the chronology that
your your film show is wrong because it
starts as if you know the stroke of the
pen bite by Donald Trump was it wise was
it not wise I don't know it was the
beginning Iran has been used you said it
has been attacking in the region it
Syria Yemen Lebanon funding Hamas
funding terror groups all over the place
for years now and the the withdrawal
from the nuclear ruin was a retaliation
to aggression which started with Iran
now I'm not saying that's how the Arabia
for instance which is scared stiff of
Iran is that there's some kind of angels
there a horrible regime but they are a
status quo recede they don't want to
change the the delicate balance of power
in that region Iran is a revolutionary
regime still after 40 years and and and
this is this they cannot be allowed to
completely destabilize while I mean
they've already succeeded but to go on
disabled I mean Arabia doesn't have to
be a revolution regime in order to you
know reign Yemen with bombs right so I
think in terms reacting to the Houthi
aggression Laden they are funded by Iran
everyone knows that but everyone also
knows that in terms of Iranian
involvement in the region Yemen is on a
different category than Iran when it
comes to Iran's involvement in Syria
near Iraq I mean when it comes to Yemen
the you know the prime culprit is of
course Saudi Arabia so I wouldn't
conflate those two cases although you
know the Houthis are supported by Iran
without no doubt before you to continue
your Rico I thought the the nuclear deal
signed in 2015 was was a triumph of
diplomacy no I mean a triumph of stupid
in one sentence then we'll because the
deal said Iran can have a nuclear bomb
in ten years all the mourners had to do
was to wait now if that's a triumph of
diplomacy then then then then then the
Munich Agreement was was was I mean come
on promise someone you get to put the
bomb in ten years and you call it try
and prevent Iran from enriching the
atomic material for the bomb so it was
very effective and what the hope was
that once you reduce the pressure on the
regime that this Democratic Change that
was to evolve would somehow be possible
now that you really worked very well yes
no they started having demonstrations
there with all these women no longer
wearing the scarf but all these
movements are now dead because you put
on pressure on the regime so there was
the possibility of having a peaceful
change in Iran and everything's
destroyed just by it Donald Trump I mean
I don't know where to start I think I
mean I mean I I do agree with what was
said about Iran's role but probably you
know in terms of terminology I would be
more careful but I was also supported of
the Iran nuclear deal I thought that the
nuclear crisis between the west and Iran
has to be settled diplomatically this is
what happened but after that I was also
very much openly criticizing the
European policy on Iran that I
considered to be too soft if you wanted
to put it in simplistic ways but what
Europe failed to do is use the kind of
economic and political leverage that it
has had amassed in Tehran in order to
force the Iranians at least for some
gradual course corrections domestically
but also in the region so this is what
Europe you know failed to do and as a
consequence the gap between US policy on
Iran and European policy on Iran you
know wide widened immensely that's the
point I mean what would the language be
that you would use that when we talk
about the deal has it begun to unravel
is it unraveling or has it already
unravel
I mean it is definitely on the verge of
collapse and if you what would that mean
for European diplomacy in the coming
months and years it will be a disaster
because this is still the cornerstone of
European policy on Iran well this is
what's you know official European
policies has today but you know we have
to think beyond the Iran nuclear
agreement who are trying to keep it and
for that to happen the Europeans must
figure out a way to provide Iran with
economic dividends that Iran once but
this is something that is unlikely to
happen so you know there is no doubt
that the jcpoa is and you know vital
crisis but we have to move beyond not
only because of the sunset clauses of
the agreement itself that are going to
kick in in the next few years but also
because of other issues of concern that
is that are not only raised by the Trump
administration but I think we have we do
need a comprehensive approach in viewing
this region not only to look at Iran but
also to look at the structural problems
the lack of a regional security
architecture that is working and we need
really a more comprehensive
understanding what is driving
geopolitics in that region for that we
have to look also what is happening
inside of those countries the
socio-economic situation the political
situation ecological aaja collation so
all those crises also driving what we
considers to be geopolitics let's just
rewind a little bit as far as the u.s.
request for other nations to join in its
naval mission in the Gulf Berlin
responded walk with what was widely
described here as a blunt no here's the
German Foreign Minister with his
statement together with the French in
the Britons we discussed at length what
such a mission could look like also an
alternatives to the u.s. strategy of
maximum pressure on Iran which we
believe Israel
the moment is at the moment the Britons
would rather join an American mission we
won't do that what do you make of that
statement Helen they went down very well
in Germany I think most people said yes
it's the right thing to do because
Donald Trump is trigger-happy well we've
heard that Donald Trump isn't
trigger-happy there's not gonna be a war
but but what if you encourage the
Iranians they might become what
trigger-happy that this is simply a
document of cowardice and defeat were
waving the white flag we're saying to
the Iranians go on now have another
couple of tankers we are gonna be an
observer mission Oh big deal we know
who's attacking the tanker say we don't
have to observe everything anything
anymore the British I mean we're always
talking about how we want to create a
security architecture in Europe which
includes the British even if they leave
that you're in European Union and the
first thing we do is when air tankers
are attacked is to say ok you go along
with Trump he's gonna you know you're
gonna do the protection we can observe
what are we gonna do when they attack
our tankers what are we gonna do if
somewhere else our tankers are attacked
and then we go running to the British
who happen to have a navy as we don't in
this instance in terms of the vessels
they can actually send to the region not
much more than Germany well exactly but
when we when we when we actually need
help yeah this is they're gonna say well
what did you do when hours when we were
attacked I mean this is simply a
breakdown of solid Aryan and the fact I
mean what is the transatlantic
partnership therefore if you don't
happen not to like the president you
prefer to capitulate for a couple of
turban wearing ayatollahs come on I mean
here's the Democratic nation that United
States and there's a theocratic
dictatorship the choice is easy not to
Germans but you know yeah well I think
I'd like to introduce another topic
because I don't know because it may not
an economic topic because the main
problem is that the Europeans don't have
any leverage because they are bound to
the dollar as the reserve currency when
you look at why do the US sanctions work
so well it's because the dollar is
needed for everyone trading globally so
if the
Europeans really wanted to have some
leverage at all against someone like
Trump because I think that Trump really
is a very global problem then what they
needed was to have the euro as a reserve
currency and as long as the euro is weak
because of the euro crisis there will be
no European policy that can counteract
against Trump so you can just forget
about the Europeans as long as there's a
euro crisis as somebody who moves
between Doha and Berlin what's your take
on all this on the leverage that the
Europeans have the role that the
Europeans have the divisions within
Europe now with the UK on the one hand
and their continental Europeans on the
other and brexit looming well I think
that what we've been seeing over the
past few weeks and months is that not
only have there been signs from the
Trombetta Malaysian side that they're
openly you know willing to talk to the
Iranian side but also vice-versa we have
been signal you know we have seen
signals of or the Iranian Iran is
basically testing the waters in terms of
how far they can go in terms of
negotiating and and what to negotiate
about but what is still is what is still
lacking is the green light from the
Supreme Leader of Iran who is you know
that is indispensable in terms of any
kind of new you know decisions and
negotiations and in this picture
obviously the main decision will be made
in Washington and in Tehran and not in
Europe Europe of course can play a
mediating role and France has tried to
do that and it can be fruitful because
they're quiet what sir what about
Germany Germany is on holiday no I mean
basically so whether European policies
right now is that the French are doing
ice or or you know are acting on behalf
of the court European states and and and
the French are you know quite also
sharing the kind of concerns of the US
administration in terms of Iran's
regional policies much more than the
German government actually so because so
because of that actually if France could
you know play a hopeful role but then
again it's not up to Europe Alain your
newspaper is being criticized
who is criticizing from Merkel for being
inactive in in forging a proper alliance
with the III of the Europeans the French
and the Germans well and and my papers
right I mean you do we have this crisis
everyone's talking about well we we
don't believe there's gonna be a war but
their people are worried and the
Chancellor is is is silent reading a
book about Shakespeare in her summer
holidays interesting by the way a book
on the tyrant how to deal with the
tyrant and the point is Shakespeare
it's a topple him be it Macbeth be it
richard ii be it the Supreme Leader of
Iran this guy is a danger to the world
you know but they can just repeat myself
it was just the same kind of analysis
but that 2003 to the top amount of
Saddam Hussein in Iraq and it was really
a major mistake and I think that you
should not somehow always think that
whenever you feel disturbed by someone
else around the globe that you should
start a war starting a war of feeling to
surpass someone by someone and what I'm
saying is we have a Iran is aiming for
regional hegemony and for regional
destabilization and that will
destabilize your it's already started I
mean we don't have to be myopic I mean
Iran is it's not a stabilizing force in
the region but nor is you know sad Rabin
or is sometimes Israel so we have known
or is sometimes turkey for that matter
so we have to take a comprehensive
approach in order to be able to solve
the this perennial crisis that we have
in the region if we keep on you know
having I mean if the choice will be
between a military regime change policy
other neoconservatism in Iraq or
authoritarian stability policy that
you're what likes to do with all kinds
of dictatorships in the region but those
are two bad choices so we have to figure
out something you know agree beyond that
I'd love to have more time great
discussion we've been talking about the
Iran crisis Europe on the sidelines
it looks a little bit that way thanks
for joining us come back next week until
then bye-bye and truce
[Music]